The American Society of Civil Engineers gives America's infrastructure an overall grade of D+.
Meanwhile, China can't build fast enough.
Having installed six ring roads around Beijing,...
...construction crews are now working on a seventh,...
...forging ahead with plans to create a super city of 130 million people,...
...slightly larger than the population of Japan.
The National High-Speed Rail Network, nonexistent a decade ago,...
...is now more extensive than the European Union's, and expanding rapidly.
Although China wins on speed,...
...it comes at the expense of quality, safety and the environment.
And then there's the cost.
A report by academics at Oxford University's Said Business School...
...says China may be on the road to ruin.
And unless China scales back,...
...they say it's headed for an infrastructure-led financial and economic crisis.
I think it's safe to say China's had the single biggest buildout...
...of infrastructure in the history of mankind.
McKinsey calculates that between 2000 and 2014, China added 26.1 trillion dollars to its debt,...
...a figure greater than the GDP of the US, Japan and Germany combined.